[music]
>> Many a time
many of the commentaries, many of the
translations
commentaries are the translations very
rarely. They quote the Bible.
And many a time the person who doing the
commentary is not an expert in that
field.
So, he quotes
a portion
which is not mentioned in the Quran, but
that part of the Bible contradicts with
the sahih hadith.
So, if he's giving in the commentary a
portion of the Bible which is not
mentioned in the Quran, but contradicts
the sahih hadith,
that too has to be rejected.
So, therefore, you have to be very
careful while using biblical references
as a commentary for the Quran.
Can be helpful, at the same time can be
dangerous.
And this is a mistake made by many
commentators because the knowledge of
the hadith may not be that good. So,
Quran says something
like Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala told
Adam, peace be upon him, not to eat the
fruit. So, the commentary apple. Okay,
where you get this apple from Bible?
It's not the part of the Quran.
You know, the devil came in the shape of
a serpent. But, some things what they're
giving us commentary
which is mentioned in the Bible is not
given in the Quran, but given in the
sahih Hadith, that also we agree to be
correct.
But, certain things are mentioned in the
Bible which are not mentioned in the
Quran, not in the Hadith, neither
matching neither contradicting, it
becomes as mubah.
Optional.
Now, many a time the commentator may not
mention that it is
optional.
So, if it's an optional thing, there is
no haraj.
There is no problem.
But,
even that thing can be wrong, can be
right.
So, if it's a reference from the Bible
which is not countering the Quran or the
Hadith, we can use, but it need not be
correct.
It's a very important point for a da'ee
to say something which is authentic,
which we'll discuss in the structure.
I don't know how much time will I take
because the time is limited, 1 hour 50
minutes, and I can speak only on this
topic
on the Quran, and we'll try and cover as
much as we can.
So, that's the problem. We don't know
what part and where do we keep on
because all this is important,
everything is important. But, let's not
spend more time on this, but please note
that authenticity is very important.
And translation of the Quran referring
to what and how and how do you argue and
what you use when you use, what is the
hujjah, is very important.
But, to cut it short,
any commentary you read,
one is translation, one is commentary.
The problem in the translation also can
be there, but less. Commentary can have
a variety of problems.
Even translation can have.
As a whole, because of the rest of Ali
that first to comparative little bit
science little bit as though
he's referring to a person who has no
knowledge of Islam. So for a non-Muslim
per se
while giving any translation, I
personally prefer Abdullah Yusuf Ali.
Unless you're giving it to an American,
then there are other versions which is
more like Americanized English. And then
I'll come to it.
Americanized English, then you have
something in modern English, etc. But as
a whole, not too voluminous, not too
concise.
A medium one where you can read the
translation and one good point is is the
difference between commentary and
footnote. Many people think that
the footnote is a commentary.
Actually, in Abdullah Yusuf Ali, he puts
a C. What he does that before a section
starts, he gives commentary one. Means
if you read this paragraph, it gives you
a gist of the next 20 verses or next 15
verses or next 25 verses. So if you read
only C1 to the end, only the comment you
get a gist of the Quran. So if you want
just a concise comment from the Quran,
you need only C1 2 3 4 5 6 then and you
get a gist.
So in short, the translation may be
difficult. So when you read the comment,
you get a gist. So when you read the
translation, you have better
understanding. That is there in very few
translations.
Give you commentary first
then giving the translation. And one
thing good about the race of Ali that he
has tried to maintain not 100% but the
translation like though it's not exactly
word to word, but kul huwallahu ahad.
Say he's Allah one and only. This is kul
means say.
It's not a word-to-word translation, but
he tries to maintain wherever he could.
Kul, say.
Huwallahu ahad, he's Allah one and only.
Not that it's a word-to-word
word-to-word translation means exactly
literal meaning. It is not, but
to a certain extent he tried to maintain
and use the grammar correct so that it's
easier for a person to understand
because most of the Muslims
alhamdulillah read Arabic, but most of
them don't not it.
So this is another point that he has
given a word-to-word translation and
line to line.
Besides the commentary, if there's a
problem in understanding any
translation, he gives footnotes.
Footnote number 25, but it has got
errors. It's the only translation that I
know of in English which has been
subject to maximum criticism.
Because it's famous.
Who's the most influential personality
in the world?
Who? Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam.
Who is the personality against whom
maximum books are written?
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
So, just because maximum books are
written against someone that doesn't
mean he's bad.
Chances of him being good is there, but
he can be bad.
But Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
is the most influential. Because you get
influential, because you get famous,
there's bound to be more criticism. And
some of the criticism may be right, some
may be wrong. Again, Muhammad Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam all are wrong,
alhamdulillah.
But against other human beings, if
they're famous, some are right.
If he's not a person
who's good for society, most of it may
be right.
Abdullah Yusuf Ali has got negative
points, but with all the negative and
positive. So, as a dahi, if you know the
few negative major factors,
one of them is interest, one of them is
talking about Jesus Christ, peace be
upon him.
There are some things which are there.
A few of them which are major
which a person should know. Other things
uh I feel splitting hair.
Splitting hair means it is not matching
with the Arabic grammar and this, but
even if it matches, it doesn't make much
difference in the meaning or the
understanding of the Quran.
So, that is noted, alhamdulillah. You
can go ahead with it.
As I told you, there's original
translation, then there's a revised
translation of Abdullah Yusuf Ali.
Again, there is a simplified English
version.
Which is printed in India.
It's not here.
The original one from IPC is the
original
of Abdullah Yusuf Ali, but the Arabic
text is very old, kept on being
reprinted, so it's not very legible. So,
the new one done in USA was very good,
mashallah.
New Arabic The advantage of this is that
they made it two scripts. The scriptures
of Arabic are of a variety.
But the two famous ones are more called
as a Madani script, which is more
popular among the Arabs.
It's a different script. And then one
which is more popular among the Asians,
Indian, Pakistani, Bangladeshi. You
know, with the round one as Egyptian or
Misri script. They keep on giving
different names. So, they made this
because, as you know,
that
the Indian subcontinent has
approximately 1/3 of the Muslims of the
world.
More than half a billion Muslims live in
India, Pakistan, and Bangladesh.
Though, according to official
statistics, Indonesia is the country
which has the maximum number of Muslims.
And a person came and said that I'm
coming from a country with a maximum
Muslims. I won't argue with him, but
practically I feel India has more number
of Muslims than even Indonesia.
The government claims it has 14%.
Some Muslims claim 25. I put that it
will be inshallah more than 18,
according to me, 18 to 20%. So, seeing
that, I believe there are more than 225
million Muslims.
Much more than that.
So, practically I feel India has the
largest number of Muslims in the world.
But theoretically and officially,
according to country statistics,
Indonesia is number one. Pakistan number
two, India number three. That is the
reason the Hajj quota for Indonesia is
the most because the Saudi government
has a policy, coming to Saudi government
again. Policy that for Hajj they give
0.1%. 0.1% of the population of the
country, they give that many number of
Hajj visas.
So, if Indonesia claims to have about
200 or 210 million Muslims, so 210,000
Muslims are given visas for Hajj.
Pakistan claims to have 180 million, so
180,000 visas are given to Pakistan.
India claims officially at 170 million,
so 170,000
visas.
This is what is claimed by the
government. And now the Saudi government
alhamdulillah wants to increase the
quota to more than 1%.
That's the reason they're expanding the
Haram etc.
So this was the first translation which
I personally
prefer. You can give a
talk for days only on Abdullah Yusuf
Ali. Time will not permit us.
It will not permit us even if you have
10 stages of Dawah to talk only Abdullah
Yusuf Ali.
We'll go to the next translation.
This is the Sahih International.
This translation Sahih International
in this translation
you will not find the name of the
translator.
The name of the translator is not
mentioned.
It's done by
a group of
three
people.
And
many people know, many people don't know
that all these three
translators
they were women.
And
amongst one, the main translator, her
name is Umm Muhammad.
And the beauty is that
she was a revert
and the others also.
And they have married
Arabs.
So English is their mother tongue.
And they learn Arabic to a great extent.
What they have done that they did a
research of various good translations.
This was done I think back in the '90s,
somewhere around that if I'm not
mistaken.
But when it was being printed, I was
there with Abul Qasim. Abul Qasim is
again a bookstore in Jeddah. They had
the original copyrights of this and then
now it's with Al-Muntada. Al-Muntada
organization in UK,
based in Saudi Arabia.
And they had the copyrights. So, these
three ladies got together and this
English again is a simple English. So,
if you want a simple English, not the
archaic.
And they have been more careful that
they have checked with authentic Hadith.
Many a time the translator may not be so
particular about quoting only authentic
Hadith.
So, many a time the translators quote
Hadith without checking whether it's
authentic or not.
And I'll come to it when I come to the
section of Hadith.
So, these
group of three ladies were careful that
the quote Hadith it should be authentic
authentic source. But natural the later
you do the chance of it being
improvised. So, they took as a reference
of the Islamic took reference of other
translations etc. And they did
a hamdulillah good translation. So, if
anyone says I cannot
per se
I don't like the English of Abdullah
Yusuf Ali then I recommend the next is I
International.
But say International unlike doesn't
have
it has very few footnotes very few
negligible. Maybe a small percentage of
the Islamic. So, it's basically only a
translation though.
If you see here
in this full page hardly one or two
average maybe
footnotes that also one line or two
lines per page.
Unlike Abdullah Yusuf Ali the footnotes
are multiple times more voluminous than
the translation.
The footnotes of Abdullah Yusuf Ali
first of all it's in small size.
So, if you count the number of words in
the footnotes it's multiple times more
than the translation. So, only reading
translation if it takes you X number of
hours reading only footnotes will take 2
X 3 X more than that. And reading both
together would take much more time. This
has very few footnotes so small
percentage
of the translation. All lives in that.
So, if you don't understand one
particular
portion of the Quran,
you don't have any backup information.
That's a big drawback.
In Abdullah Yusuf Ali read the
translation, if you want, you check the
footnotes or you skip it. You have the
option.
Which is not available here, but amongst
the new translations in modern English,
this is the best and the safest because
it is relying more on authentic sources.
Unlike other translators, they aren't
very particular. They say hadith khalas
hadith.
Whether they say zaif
no problem.
But as the Hujjah, we only take sahih
hadith, which we shall come to later on.
>> [music]
[music]